[Applause]
kraft or black like any offense briefing
online and live we all come there
apologies to m
gianni da ros next weekend
I cancel any star they will succeed in
seducing then david his bathroom which
are political representations  in
chad to challenge the best and I pass
the floor directly to christian
welcome christian and happy new year
hello and happy new year my question where
will be to peter this us and they
actually concern confirmation
by my eyes one of iran's decision
to start  his process of producing
20% ​​enriched uranium
when i saw the the the first
election which last year which was
very conditional since he was
indeed awaiting the decision and the
comment of the yom it remains to be seen whether
today  today you have a reaction to
this decision
is what you consider
that indeed the action taken by the
Iranian authorities and reversible is
what you agree with the
affirmations  ns according to which it
respects article 36 of the rope 2015
is in fact more generally what
you consider that indeed with
this
decision iran has just buried the court 2015
thank you thank you I actually pass the
floor to peter stein
hello thank you christiane  yes a of course
there are a few things to add m
so we note with grave
concern
the actions taken by the rats do want
to begin
uranium enrichment at the breakdowns % this
action will only constitute one and four
significant relative  to
iran's nuclear commitments under jessy
pi ears c which will have serious
consequences and implications for nuclear non-
proliferation one day two
calls to recall another time
the importance of avoiding any measure that
could compromise the preservation
of c'  agrees but at the same
time we point out that despite
this
regrettable measure a price per li ran of
the important elements of the jessy  pi high and
in particular the strict
verification and transparency measures remain in
place this
is very important so based on
the ministerial declaration of the
participants of an object if bungie 6-1
last year december 1 in first
december  we will redouble our efforts
to preserve the noose and return to its
full implementation by all
parties this party thank you pitt are there
any other questions for peter on
this or other
international relations topics
nawab or wait while  christian
first of all i see you have a fact in europe
if i understand correctly yes yes he
just wanted a fire law since you do
not actually consider this
ministerial meeting convened by
mr morel around the jce ip agreement or a
way to retain it
it is not a snub on the part
of iran to inflict this decision on you
when everything is done for
the other signatories to
effectively maintain this agreement and
preserve it  have you
been warned? I thought I understood that
there was a goal of power in Iran
between the president and the very hard-line members of
the assembly who imposed the adoption of
this measure, but hey, that's it  is
internal cuisine in iran but for
you how do you live the fact
that barely ten days ago
you had a ministerial meeting of the
whole jce ipo group and that we are
tossing this decision  to increase to 20%
thank you as in the past is a
regrettable action but it is
very important it is also very important relay follow-up
at the conclusion of these
ministerial meetings we boast first of the
dark and the very clear declaration of
all the participants that they  are
interested in maintaining this agreement this
unclear agreement because it is a
very important piece of the nuclear
non-proliferation architecture request
and we are working together to
have a situation where all the
participants the participants respect
the  obligations which are which are there
in this agreement it is our objective
these are our effort to preserve to
preserve corsica is also to
ensure that all participants
respect the obligations death of agreement
but if I pass the floor now
anna web  show hello town hall for
reconciliations process in lack of
golf appearances therefore crisis in
whyte as for hospitals
but until then the important steps to be
you need is here as an operation
victim original drawings group i can't
be orders  indies respect of medina
baye kaolack rice of the gulf cooperation
management have five episodes
philippe yes hello my part also
obviously for if the game continues
the journey after the gulf
iran africa concerning the central
african republic I wanted to know if
beyond the press release  of this morning joint
african union un
if there are more comments and
reactions or concern in the wake
of the election p  residential we see we are
witnessing a kind of
rebel offensive underway in the country with
the appearance of troops
from abroad so is
this a risk of additional regional conflagration
in the eastern region
-does this pose specific concerns
for the missions of the
european union in the country
the military training mission but
also the civilian mission what are
the additional comments added
thank you thank you philippe peter replaces
nabila so i'm going back to him
thank you done women i am afraid
there is not is any new item to
add because the
joint statement contains all the
important items that we can say in
these two moments we are of course following
the situation has the development in
the Central African Republic very
welcoming with a lot of attention from
are very active
go this development we continue
followed the development we will
react  but in this moment we are
going we have said all that we
want in it it is a joint press release
with the international partner
thank you
peter are there any other international relations questions
for peter today
I do not see any and so I will go back  game
not his word to odile who obviously had a
question about the seabed
or the protection of the seabed
odile happy new year we only yes hello and
happy new year
e me I wanted to know if in the
services of the commission there are
studies of  impact on the protection
of the seabed in particular in the
in the northern area beyond Brittany
because there was during the holidays
and there was a great mobilization of
local elected officials is also different
rivera concerning the installation of
62 and  wind turbine right in the
famous scallop shell dfd fishing area
among others and so I wanted to
know there are impact studies that have
been done in your  services to those on this
subject thank you gentlemen, please provide a small
clarification before giving the floor to
viviane the commission carries out
impact studies in relation to its own
legislative proposals
there may of course be
evaluations made
on community policies in
general  when we talk about impact studies,
we are talking about something very
specific that concerns
studies and technical assessments that
actually allow me to justify the
proposals that we make by having
studied the different
options and possible scenarios that  said
I pass the floor to viviane more
generally on this point hello thank you
I hope the connection is working
morning thank you odile for this question
indeed heard your reference is made
then report that the
commission adopted in June 2020 and I
can send you after the  which is
exactly on the implementation of the
framework decision would be our strategy
m  arine and there we explain in detail
what the situation and the situation in
europe with regard to the protection of
the seabed
we have made a lot of effort but
indeed we still have sea
where we see difficulties with
regard to a few teeth a few
fishing activities which are not or
which are not really as
protective as we would like them to be
we also have questions of pollution
whose time there in the report and will
therefore be on the question that you asked
concerning exactly as well  the situation
in atlantic europe
it is in our joint 2020 report that
we gave a lot more
details
thank you here you go odile so we will
send the contact details so that
you can find this report so
I am now opening the debates to other
subjects I see  that yanis there will be
vocation in swing jazzy
expekt stéphane gilli of knowledge of
all by mom the style care like any
French sport of vaccination pev
cha  rango 19mn says their door a
rival offer governed mourgues we wish
post 5 stéphane des nations
[Music]